let's talk networking as we ring in a
new year welcome back to another edition
of Udacity career tips my name is Martin
McGovern and today we are diving into
tip number 14
what are your job search New Year's
resolutions New Year's is a time for
fresh starts to shake off the cobwebs of
the previous year and get out there and
try something new maybe you're gonna go
to the gym maybe you're gonna start
eating right but what are you doing for
your career how will you make 2019 the
year you finally find your dream job
easy
make it a resolution we chose to make
networking the new year's resolution for
2019 because 80% of jobs are found
through networking so if you're not
going to network this year in 2020 when
we do this again you're going to be in
the exact same place that you are today
let's set a goal and make a pledge
repeat after me this year I resolve to
make networking a priority to reach out
to new people connect those I already
know and bring value to everyone that I
meet in 2019 are you with us if so take
the first step add your name location
job title and LinkedIn URL in the
comments below and invite the community
to connect with you so you can help
build each other's networks in the new
year let's all succeed in 2019 that's it
for tip 14 make networking a New Year's
resolution and if you're looking for
more check out the rest of our Udacity
career tips on LinkedIn and YouTube
click the link in the description to go
to udacity.com and see all of our other
career resources and if you know someone
who's looking for a job right now
tag them in the comments and let them
know that you're thinking about it we
wish you the best of luck in your job
search and look forward to seeing you
again in the New Year